leadership going forward is only going
to be great if women are at 50% hi I'm
Sally Ellison I'm an author speaker and
leadership development consultant and I
work all over the world here I'm going
to talk about five of those behaviors
that most commonly get in women's ways
the first behavior is a reluctance to
claim your achievements expecting others
to spontaneously notice and reward your
contributions and your hard work when I
do workshops now I often ask how good
are you at bringing attention to your
work and what I often hear is I'm not
good at that at all and when I ask them
why aren't you good I hear one of two
responses the first is I would think
that if I do good work people should
notice they probably should but I don't
think it's gonna happen in today's
workplace the other thing I hear is if I
have to act like that obnoxious jerk
down the hall to get noticed I'd rather
not get noticed and that's problematic
because it behaves an either/or way of
thinking that is going to get in your
way if you set yourself up either you're
obnoxious and constantly talking about
yourself or you just hang back and hope
others notice you've got a kind of
no-win place to be for example you might
identify you know I think that my boss
doesn't really understand how
well-connected I am in this organization
so I think what I'm going to do is once
a week I'm going to shoot him a quick
email that just summarizes the main
people that I've managed to talk to that
week I have seen this be remarkably
successful for women
the second behavior is the disease to
please that is hoping and wanting
everyone to think you are a wonderful
and always nice person now this is a
typical behavior that can be very
helpful early in your career but can
really get in your way as you seek to
run
why is that true first of all if you're
always seeking to please you're going to
have a hard time holding other people
accountable for showing up for what
they've promised because you're going to
be afraid that maybe they won't like you
you're going to have a hard time saying
no to things and end up saying yes to
often and you're going to let people
who'll take advantage violate your own
boundaries and waste a lot of time we're
not saying here that you don't want to
be a wonderful person but being invested
in everyone thinking you're wonderful
and nice is if you seek to rise going to
get in your way if you can start small
again by asserting boundaries in one way
say to yourself right now I'm over
commited so that in the next month when
people ask me to join a new task force
or something else I'm going to think
about it very deliberately before I say
yes and I'm not only going to think
about how would it please them but I'm
going to think about how might it serve
me is this really in my best interests a
third behavior that often gets in
woman's way is perfectionism trying to
put so much energy into doing everything
right that you can't see the forest
through the trees and you waste a lot of
time trying to make improvements at the
margins that aren't going to necessarily
position you to move higher one big
problem with being a perfectionist is
that you'll have trouble delegating work
to other people because you're so
invested in it being perfect you're
going to be afraid that they'll make
mistakes so you'll end up doing often a
lot of work of other peoples yourself
and I often hear perfectionist say oh
it's just easier to do everything myself
now again you want to start small here
you might just want to identify one
person who you're going to decide to
delegate to give them an opportunity
offer them feedback but don't stay
on top of it and take that risk one of
the things that's really interesting is
that studies showed that women and
organizations tend to be more rewarded
for being precise and correct whereas
men and organizations tend to be
rewarded more for risk-taking and
boldness so as you seek to rise you want
to learn to take risks and move away
from being overly precise and
perfectionistic the fourth behavior is
ruminating over the mistakes you've made
this can really keep you stuck and it's
much more common in women than men
research has shown that rumination is
much more likely to be a behavioral
impediment for women it's a form of
beating yourself up rather than letting
mistakes go and figuring your human
being and you will make mistakes
like everyone else finally minimizing
either in terms of the speech or
minimizing in terms of how you hold your
physical self in the world
women can be reluctant to hold their
space that is shrinking their body at
times or not really standing up with
Authority as if they belong where they
are especially when they're at higher
echelons or trying to position
themselves as a leader women often will
also use minimizing phrases in their
speech oh do you just have one minute
can I only make one point and of course
our old favorite apologizing is a form
of minimizing yourself so what you want
to do if you trying to position yourself
as a leader is to hold your space and
show up as if you know that you are
worthy whole and complete
but I want to point out but I've been
doing a lot of interviews in a lot of
events and I can't tell you how many
times people have said men have said to
me I really identify with some of these
behaviors and that speaks to a I think a
greater commonality between women and
men that is one of the real forces that
is driving and changing the workplace
you